el precio del barril de petróleo no ha
dejado de subir en los últimos meses y
se ha disparado literalmente desde el
estallido de la guerra el resultado un
aumento del 47% en tres meses por un
depósito lleno de gasolina yo diría que
son 510 euros más es un shock así que
solo me lleve 50 euros voy a tener que
arreglármelas tendremos que adaptarnos
no se suponía llenar el depósito pero
ahora lo hago algunos distribuidores de
combustible aseguran que su precio de
compra ya aumentó 10 céntimos en los
últimos días por lo tanto el alza para
los clientes podría ser aún más brutal
la próxima semana otros sectores también
están preocupados empezando por la
agricultura que se ve directamente
afectada por la subida de las materias
primas rusia es un gran exportador de
cereales como el trigo pero también de
fertilizantes a europa
en este momento los piensos cuestan 330
euros tonelada lo que ya es enorme el
año pasado estaba a 240 en la misma
época salvo que ahora se habla de
cuatrocientos euros o incluso más por
una tonelada así que es increíble y ya
estamos en números rojos no sé a dónde
vamos
otras industrias especialmente afectadas
son la automovilística la cosmética y la
aeronáutica tras la prohibición de que
las compañías aéreas de 36 países
sobrevuelen el territorio ruso los
aviones que se dirigen al continente
asiático deben tomar nuevas rutas para
evitar el país el precio de los tiquetes
debería sufrir pronto un golpe
el aumento de los costes de explotación
de los aviones es porque estamos
consumiendo más combustible porque vamos
a pagar más tasas aeroportuarias más
tasas de aterrizaje más tasas de
sobrevuelo esto va a tener un coste que
para las compañías aéreas es quizás del
30 al 40 por ciento para estas rutas
hacia áfrica hacemos las sanciones
impuestas a rusia afectarán
considerablemente a la economía rusa
pero no dejarán de tener consecuencias
para las economías europeas